be interesting to get your reaction to
Liz truss's speech should she be given
some credit for accepting that there was
a problem a big problem and she has
acted on it and knowing that it won't
please everybody but she's accepted that
something needs to be done
not at all look she has trashed the
British economy she's put hundreds of
pounds on people's mortgages and she's
humiliated the conservative government
uh in the eyes of the world people are
angry they're they're fed up and and
they're worried about the future and
above all they're furious with the
conservative party that's why it's time
they had to say the people had their say
that's why it is time for a general
election
good news about the corporation tax
though the u-turn on that it's going to
bring in 18 billion pounds which the
country needs
well liberal Democrats opposed uh the
Liz trust plan to cut it in the first
place uh we also think there should be a
windfall tax on the oil and gas company
profits we should also not give the
banks the cut with the reduction in the
levy that would enable us to have a lot
more money to help people and businesses
and have a more fiscally sound budget
which would take the pressure off
mortgage rates we've got to help people
struggling with their mortgages at the
moment and we've got to help people with
their energy bills and you've got to
find the money for that and so liberal
Democrats have got a lot of positive
proposals there and it's been the fee of
the conservative government and their
MPS to go in completely opposite
direction that's led to the pain that so
many homeowners and businesses are
feeling
this country does have low investment
low growth low wages it needs bold moves
doesn't it do you think that there can
be a reset now and perhaps Jeremy Hunt
is the person to do that
well I have some doubts about Jeremy
Hunt partly because of his record as
secretary say for health
many of his policies and approaches
there have led to the problems we've
seen the Health Service and now care
services now so it's so important that
we get a Health Service right and he's
got a pretty poor record and then also
um on the economy he fought the toy
leadership twice in 2019 and 2022 and
his Flagship policies were Cuts in
corporation tax even deeper than uh Liz
truss and quasiquarteng so I'm not even
convinced he's got the right approach on
the economy and that's why liberal
Democrats are clear frankly it doesn't
matter whether it's Boris Johnson Liz
trust quality quad Tango Jeremy Hunt
it's a whole lot of them I think people
have lost trust with the conservative
party and understandably so we fought
three by-elections in the last year or
so in Tory heartlands and liberal
Democrats beat the conservatives in Tory
heartlands in True Blue Buck Insurance
by-election just over a year ago then
North Shropshire a seat that tourism
held for 200 100 years in the East East
Devon last last summer and you know when
we knocked on doors and spoke to
lifelong conservatives they said the
conservative party was taking them for
granted the conservative party either
didn't get it or didn't care and was out
of touch so that's why we are clear the
conservatives have got to be got rid of
and we need a general election to let
the people do that
yeah I mean you you talk about a general
election and and we've heard all the
reasons uh from Samus to to how a
general election could potentially come
about but you're not in a brilliant
position are you in the lib Dems because
people in this country don't feel that
you've necessarily got fire in your
belly that you could come up with a
fiscal plan that's better than anyone
else's to get out of the mess that we're
in I totally disagree with you
um not only did we win three bar
elections I mentioned we also the last
May elections we had huge numbers of
people coming to the liberal Democrats
we had the best results across the whole
of the United Kingdom so people are
coming to our cause politically and when
we look at solutions to our economic
mess it was the liberal Democrats who
first proposed a windfall tax then
copied by labor and the Tories
unfortunately didn't do it properly but
they tried to do some sort of windfall
tax we led the debate on that and then
at the beginning of the summer we led
the debate saying that the energy price
cap should be frozen shouldn't go up
labor and then cop does again and then
the Tories did something again not very
good because they still allow people's
bills to go up by another 500 pounds so
we've been leading the intellectual
debate on the economy uh we've got a
whole set of economic policies which
were really positive and would help grow
our economy in a sustainable way that
would be fair that would ensure we did
have a green economy and that we cared
for people and that vision of a fairer
Greener more caring country the liberal
Democrat vision is I think something
that will resonate with voters does
resonate with voters and they know that
the conservatives will never deliver
that
yeah I mean it's easy to to to blame the
conservatives for the situation we're in
but of course well they have been in
power for quite a few years
say you've been in power and you've
never messed it up you've messed up my
point
and we are people are crossed about them
I'm sorry people are angry and don't
don't put it away the conservatives are
to blame
no no my point is that economies around
the world are struggling and suffering
and uh part of that is because of the
war in Ukraine part of it is because of
the struggles recovering from a
post-covered world so you can't lay
everything at the door of the Tory party
well you're right there are some
International pressures covid Ukraine
but then if you compare how other
countries have dealt with those
challenges and how they are now the true
Fae of the conservist becomes even
clearer if you look for example at
Future growth prospects you know take
the oecd and IMF analysis who look at
all the countries
the UK and the conservatives bottom of
the league except for Russia
that is the record of the conservatives
internationally so yes there are
international pressures but other
countries I'm sad to say have dealt with
them much much better
and the conservatives have failed our
country and they've failed it really
badly and because conservative MPS
frankly should do their patriotic Duty
and allow a general election
okay so Davey leader of the live Dems
correct getting your reaction thank you
very much for that